- Thanks to Skillshare for
keeping Legal Eagle in the air.
Learn to think like a lawyer
for free for two months
by clicking the link in the description.
The president has declared
a national emergency
and is using that as
justification to build his wall.
Can he do that?
(orchestral musical flourish)
In ancient Rome, the dictator
was a temporary position
given to the head of state
in times of emergency.
So giving emergency power to the president
is not a new idea, but there's nothing
like that in the Constitution.
The Constitution makes no
provision for a national emergency
and does not recognize
anything like emergency powers.
But some argue that the president
has been delegated those
powers by Congress.
So today, we're gonna talk
about President Trump's
emergency declaration.
Number one, I wanna talk
about what emergency powers
the president does actually have.
Number two, I wanna talk
about whether there is,
in fact, an emergency that allows
the president to invoke those powers.
Number three, I wanna
talk about what powers
Congress has and which it has
bestowed on the president,
and number four, I wanna talk
about the possible outcomes
that may come as a result
of this national emergency
declaration and what that
means for future presidents.
In other words, are we going to see a lot
of new declarations of national
emergencies over things
like the environment, gun
control, or healthcare.
So let's talk about the first question.
What emergency powers does
the president have, and can
the president act outside
of those enumerated powers?
Well, with few exceptions, the president
can only act with
Congressional authorization.
The president has broad executive
and enforcement authority
to use his or her discretion to determine
how to enforce the law or
how to otherwise manage
the resources of the executive branch,
but the president has
virtually no authority
to pass laws or appropriate
funds without Congress.
And in fact, in the famous case
of Youngstown Sheet and
Tube Company v. Sawyer,
the Supreme Court ruled that
President Harry Truman's
attempt to nationalize US
steel mills during a strike
in the Korean war was in
fact unconstitutional.
So as one Congressperson has said,
if Harry Truman couldn't
nationalize the steel industry
during wartime, this president
doesn't have the power
to declare an emergency and build
a multi-billion-dollar wall on the border.
Now, one of the first fundamental
issues that is implicated
by this emergency declaration
is the appropriations issue.
According to Article
One of the Constitution,
only Congress can
appropriate federal funds.
Article One, Section One of
the US Constitution states
that all legislative
powers herein are granted
and shall be vested in the Congress.
Article One, Section
Eight states that Congress
has the exclusive
spending power to, quote,
provide for the general
welfare of the United States.
Lawsuits have already been filed stating
that President Trump has
violated the United States
Constitution's separation
of powers doctrine
by taking executive action
to fund a border wall
without Congress actually
appropriating the correct funding.
Those lawsuits have argued that
the 2019 Appropriations Act
is an explicit denial of the president's
requested funds for the border wall.
Those lawsuits also
argue that the president
has violated the separation
of powers doctrine
by unilaterally diverting
funds that Congress
has already appropriate for other things
that are not related to the border wall,
and Article One, Section Nine
of the Constitution states
that no money shall be
drawn from the treasury
but in consequence of
appropriations made by law.
The lawsuits argue that Congress heard
the president's request and
explicitly rejected the request
to appropriate funds to build
any kind of border wall.
So the recent attorney's
general lawsuit argues
that President Trump violated
the appropriations clause
of the Constitution
by funding construction for
a border wall with funds
that were not appropriated
for that purpose.
But here, the Trump
administration will counter
that Congress has, in fact, passed a law
that gives him authority to do this.
A number of laws do in fact
authorize the president
to take certain actions by
declaring a national emergency.
The primary law the president
seems to be operating
under is the National
Emergencies Act of 1976,
as amended in 1985, which governs
the president's declaration
of a national emergency.
Now, under the NEA, the
president must specifically state
the law under which he proposes to act,
and he still has to comply with
the provisions of that law.
This is incredibly important,
because the redesignated funds
must still comply with the original law
under which the funds were appropriated.
The first preliminary
issue is can the president
even invoke the NEA in
these circumstances?
The question is, is there an
emergency, and it also depends
on what the definition of an emergency is.
The term emergency is not defined
in the National Emergencies
Act, and this fact
cuts in a couple of different directions.
On the one hand, some argue
that this gives the
president carte blanche
to declare anything an
emergency, because the NEA
doesn't specify what
constitutes an emergency.
But I think that misses the point.
One of the jobs of the courts
from time immemorial is
to provide definitions
where a particular statute
is silent or ambiguous.
In the case of federal
laws, courts often look
to the intent of Congress
to impute a definition
to an otherwise undefined
term, and let's be clear,
there is no emergency as most
people understand that word.
Merriam-Webster's defines
emergency as a, quote,
unforeseen combination of circumstances
of the resulting state that
calls for immediate action.
President Trump has said himself
that this was not strictly necessary.
He could have gone
through regular channels,
but he wanted to do if faster.
- I wanna do it faster.
I could do the wall over
a longer period of time.
I didn't need to do this.
But I'd rather do it much faster.
- And in the present day,
illegal immigration is
at near historic lows.
The president may not be
satisfied with those numbers,
but as most people understand
the lay definition of emergency,
it doesn't seem like there's
any against that it fits.
It seems very likely that this
is not the kind of situation
that Congress had in mind
when passing the 1976
National Emergencies Act.
In fact, that particular
law was an attempt
to curtail presidential power
that had been exercised by
the Nixon administration.
So it is possible that the
court will defer to whatever
the president declares
as a national emergency.
I don't think the courts
that look at this will do so,
in part because of the
political ramifications.
It might allow future presidents
to declare whatever they
want as an emergency.
But that being said, it isn't uncommon
for courts to have to
weigh in on the definitions
of terms in various laws, and if the court
uses a lay definition of emergency,
then it's likely that
this particular situation
would not qualify, and
that may end the analysis
of this particular legal
question right there.
But let's assume for the sake of argument
that this does qualify
as a national emergency,
or the court takes a
deferential view that says
basically anything can
be a national emergency.
Now that means that we have
to look at the second part.
What laws are invoked in order
to reappropriate the funds,
because, as I mentioned before,
the president still has to
comply with the underlying laws
that passed the funds in the first place.
One of the laws the
president is relying on
to see the lion's share
of the billions of dollars
he's asking for border wall construction
deals with military construction.
Under this military construction
law, 33 U.S.C. 2293,
the president may terminate
or defer military construction
that he has deemed not essential
to the National Defense,
and may apply those
resources for a project
to construct another project
which he considers essential.
But the reappropriated funds
under this particular law
must still constitute
military construction,
and given the fact that we
are not at war with Mexico,
it makes it a hard sell to
claim that a border wall
is a military construction project.
In addition, this particular
construction project
does not require the
armed forces to build,
and in fact, there's
an argument to be made
that the military cannot be used to build
this particular project under
the Posse Comitatus rule.
Posse Comitatus is a
doctrine that is enshrined
in statutory law in the
United States that says
you cannot use the military
for domestic projects,
especially not enforcement.
You might recall that when
President Trump sent troops
to the border to fight
against an alleged caravan
of potential immigrants and refugees,
they weren't actually send
to the border to fight
but really to only provide backup services
to the Department of Homeland Security.
That was largely because of the
doctrine of Posse Comitatus,
which says that you cannot
use armed forces domestically.
So even if the president is
able to get over the hurdle
of declaring a national emergency,
he's still going to have
a number of hurdles with
respect to the underlying law
from which he is taking
the appropriated funds.
Now, on the other hand, the
government will probably argue
that the courts should
give broad deference
to the president's
determination that there is
a national emergency,
and also broad deference
as to what constitutes
military construction.
As the Commander-in-Chief
of the armed forces,
we don't often want to
be able to second-guess
the Commander-in-Chief's
ability to declare
what is essential to the
national defense and what isn't.
So if this case gets to the
Supreme Court and isn't bounced
on some technicality,
it's completely unclear
which way the Supreme
Court might go on this.
There are long strings of
cases that are deferential
to the president and the
president's authority
to act where the Constitution allows it.
So this is certainly not a
slam-dunk for either side,
and this is also one of those
areas where the traditional
cleavages of liberal versus
conservative justices
on the Supreme Court
don't always make sense.
Sometimes, the conservative justices
vote to curtail executive
power, and sometimes,
the more liberal members of
the Supreme Court take the view
that the executive powers
should be very expansive.
So when it comes to who might
view this as an overreach
and who might view this as
a perfectly reasonable thing
for a president to do, all bets are off.
I should note, however,
that litigation over this
emergency declaration
is going to have issues
with standing and ripeness.
This is always a perennial
issue when you have
these kinds of acts and
political questions,.
In order to file a lawsuit,
you have to have what's called standing,
which means that you have
to be personally aggrieved
in order to file suit,
and in terms of standing,
individual members of
Congress do not have standing,
but sometimes Congress as a body does.
Sometimes affected states have standing;
sometimes they don't.
There's also the issue of ripeness.
Since only the declaration
has been made and no action
has actually been taken, it's not clear
that this case is actually
ripe for adjudication,
but the recent litigation
in California which deals
with dozens of states, dozens
of states' attorneys general,
and several farmers who are likely
to be affected by this
emergency declaration
looks to solve some of those
standing and ripeness issues,
but no matter what, this
will have huge implications
for future presidential actions.
Those on both sides of the
aisle are right to worry
about the president in
this particular setting.
When the Senate passed the
National Emergencies Act,
it stated in the notes of passage
that the NEA was designed to ensure
that the president's
extraordinary emergency powers
would be utilized only when
emergencies actually exist.
Under the National Emergencies
Act, Congress has 18 days
to adopt a joint resolution
to terminate the declaration,
but that joint resolution is
subject to a presidential veto.
A recent Supreme Court
authority has stated that
a presidential veto can only
be overturned by a two-thirds
vote in both houses, and
this is incredibly unlikely.
So that means that if the court upholds
the Trump administration's
declaration of emergency here,
the likely outcome is
that the next president,
and potentially the president after that,
is likely to be able to
declare almost anything
a national emergency in that case as well,
and at least in my opinion, that seems
like exactly what the
framers of the Constitution
tried to avoid when they gave
the exclusive right to pass
laws and the exclusive right
to make appropriations only to Congress.
President Trump made a
major mistake by saying
that he didn't need to issue
the declaration of emergency
and could have used the
regular legislative process.
He really could have benefited
from Soledad O'Brien's
Skillshare class, Powerful
Storytelling Today.
If he had taken a class
on crafting a great story and message,
his legal defense would
be in much better shape.
He also could have benefited
from Simon Sinek's class
on how to share ideas that inspire action,
because so far, the only
action that President Trump
has inspired is a bunch of lawsuits.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that has over 20,000
classes on everything,
like leadership, technology, and business.
The first 500 Legal Eagles
will get two free months
of Skillshare when you
click on the link below.
The free premium membership gives you
unlimited access to must-know topics
so you can improve your
skills and learn new things.
Improve yourself now
and avoid your own personal emergencies.
So click on the link, get two free months,
and start learning to
think like a lawyer today.
So, do you agree?
Leave your objections in the comments.
Check out my other real law reviews here
for more legal analysis,
and until next time,
I'll see you in court.